Speaker 1: Let's go to Andrew
from Brooklyn. Andrew, welcome.
Speaker 4: Hi, David.
Speaker 1: Can you hear me? Yes, I can.
Speaker 4: Okay. So I was talking with some
friends the other day, which I'm with the J
six hearings and so forth. And they're not right
wing or left wing or progressive, so on and so
forth. And they felt like actually maybe.
Speaker 1: Right, hold on.
Let me just see if you're saying the people you
were talking to aren't right wing or
left wing. They are progressive. Isn't
progressive the same as left wing?
Speaker 4: Yes, Chris. So centrist,
I guess you would call yourself.
I'm not really sure what they call.
Speaker 1: The way they are.
Or they are not progressives.
Speaker 4: I don't remember. But they don't
consider themselves either Democrat or Republican.
Speaker 1: Okay. All right. Go on.
Speaker 4: They're interracial.
They're an interracial couple. My friend Coles had
had had an abortion. And but as far as J six is
concerned, they were saying, you know, maybe we
should, you know, overthrow our government or at
least overhaul it. I mean, it has so many and not
in the way it was done on J six, obviously. But
what's your feeling? I mean, do we need
like a complete overhaul of the government,
the US government?
Speaker 1: Uh, no, I don't
think so. I mean, it depends on what you have
in mind. I think there's a lot of problems that
I would try to solve. Like, for example, I think
we should have a national popular vote vote rather
than an electoral college. I just don't think an
overthrow is going to achieve that because of the
framework that exists legally in the country.
I'm not sure. I mean, I think I almost anyone
would agree that there are things that need to be
fixed and repaired, but that an overthrow of the
government is unlikely to achieve that.
Speaker 4: Right. Well,
I actually met overhaul. Not over through.
Speaker 1: Yeah, sure. There's lots of things
that need to be overhauled. We need to overhaul
how health insurance is organized in the country.
We need to overhaul how we do elections, overhaul
campaign finance. There's tons of stuff that needs
to be a police reform and on and on. But I'm
with you there. We definitely need an overhaul.
Speaker 4: Yeah. And I mean, I had a terminal
brain cancer and two brain surgeries,
which I talked about on your channel in the
chat and so forth. And I mean, my $500,000,
you know, medical bill uninsured, the medical
system for sure needs an overhaul. I again,
I'm saying overhaul, not overthrow.
Speaker 1: I'm with you. Absolutely.
Absolutely. Need an overhaul. Right.
Speaker 4: So I'm I just want you know,
I really appreciate your show and that Jack broke
the rules and asked you how you're doing, so.
Speaker 1: I know. I know. That was horrible. That
was horrible. Andrew, thank you for the call.
Speaker 2: All right, brother.
Speaker 1: All right. Take care. There's
Andrew from Brooklyn, wishing you the best.